and called me a racist for no reason  this guy and the white house i said that  sounds a bit racist because you said  everybody over here is a lot of white  i've seen a lot of white people all  right say that i said race oh that is  yeah that's not that's not racist  what does it matter if everyone's people  are white by the way he's black did you  know that that's not racist that  gentleman is dating effect oh okay the  people who are organizing this event are  white okay is that racist white guy and  brown or yellow guy i'm mexican brown  mexican brown guy that's how  because you said white so i thought  color was the right way to do it right  no when you go what should i say i'm  sorry when you go take a test is there a  yellow box there's a white box  so white is okay but not yellow or brown  that's  y'all are the ones that created these  tests  i didn't create any tests what are you  talking about